talk about um
a lot of newer rap fans might have just
heard you for the first time on goodkid
mad city
right which is one of the greatest
hip-hop albums ever uh
shout out to kendrick shout out to
kendrick shout out to kendrick shout out
to top dog dre
um just that that record is like
just the way it switches up and then you
come in it's like oh yeah that was that
man that was probably one of the things
that was probably one of the best you
know uh guest appearances i've done or
working with kendrick
because my dude no
what he wanted he are he sees his vision
he sees his direction
and he came about at a different
approach than what we usually used to as
far as west coast artists
who come from that situation you know
poverty you know gang banging
we usually turn out the cmws the nwas
the cubes the whatever
and he was able to
[Music]
take it to a different level almost like
from the perspective of the kid who
grows up in that
i grew up everybody banging around me
everybody's selling dope my brother my
uncle my
[ __ ] and i am the straightforward kid
but i'm still here so i get to witness
everything not that i'm a part of it
because even though
i don't have to say it they gonna
protect me or they're gonna affiliate me
with over here or whatever
but i'm just a kid on the straight path
who see the pitfalls
and i'm trying to avoid that so as soon
as i hooked up with him he knew what he
wanted he knew where he wanted to go
how he wanted he was telling me [ __ ] i
want you to do this i want you to do
this i want you to do that
and you got to respect the [ __ ]
like that he didn't come into the game
playing with nothing i'm not gonna play
around with this [ __ ]
were you like aware because obviously at
that point in time kendrick was
definitely buzzing dread
yeah section 80 already came out i
wasn't aware of kendrick at all so you
weren't aware of like the
magnitude of like yo this [ __ ] i
i uh started [ __ ] with kendrick
because
my son's sister knew of him
and she called me and said they were
trying to get in contact with me
i didn't know anything about kendrick i
didn't know about section 80 none of
that
[ __ ] no just like i mean all right my
son's sister called me and said eight
uh this guy named kendrick he's messing
with dre
blah blah blah they want to get you on
the song and i was like yeah okay
what what was it that did because you
know there's so many
iconic rappers from compton but i
thought it was so dope that he put you
on that record because it wasn't like
expected and it was very like i'm pretty
sure it wasn't expected from anyone
no i remember i saw that i was like oh
[ __ ] yeah this one got mc8
or the [ __ ] album about compton like
jesus christ
like i said i didn't even i didn't even
i put nothing to it when i came when i
showed up at the studio
i mean we recorded the song in carson
right at the spot
so i just looked at it is my nigga's one
of these up-and-coming rappers he got
skills
and blah blah and then i think the
minute after i recorded the song i went
home that night
and then everything was kindred kindred
kendrick
whoa i'm like oh he signed the dre and
monty won't and then next day you know
aftermath hit me
and top dog and punch and [ __ ] was
like hey
and i was like they was like you know
you're the only [ __ ]
who got to be on the record you drake
and i think
mary j yeah that was it they didn't let
anybody else on the record so i was like
whoa
okay so good look that's why it's a
good-looking dre
uh tde all that because he could have
chose anybody
yeah especially with dre behind him you
know dre would be like
i don't want that [ __ ] i want
that but when they said dre
said [ __ ] it cool i just looked at it as
they
they looked at it as i was a [ __ ]
coming from compton
who my whole career i was just one path
i didn't try to go here here come here
or here i just stuck to cmw
type of [ __ ] the neighborhood whatever
so that song was
perfect to try to throw me on i also
feel like it was a dope homage to your
career because you're somebody who
is very underappreciated in the grand
scheme of
when we discuss west coast hip hop
definitely you're very underrated
your uh catalog is is you know
fire and i feel like that was a dope
like tip to what you've been doing i i i
took that from
his point of view as well i looked at
it as you know he respected
true west coast hip hop and coming from
compton
you know we got dre we got you know
quick is there you know so
i'm like but i've always stuck to that
you've always
been i've always been consistent with
what i do so
coming from compton to pay i'm like he's
already [ __ ] with dre
you know what i'm saying so i just
looked at it like yeah
let's get somebody that we feel has
always represented the city of compton
always been consistent and like you said
underrated and don't get that much shine
and pay a mod so
i didn't even i didn't even question
money or anything
that's fine when they hit me up i just
went to the studio i wasn't like oh well
he signed the dre how much y'all finna
pay me
i went to the studio dropped the verse
shook my [ __ ] hand
and we bounced and i think i heard from
them like three months later and they
was like dre
and aftermath and i was like whoa this
is gonna be some big [ __ ]
fire